un billet à son effigie un jeu de
société en son honneur ou encore des
monuments à son nom mais de qui peut-il
bien s'agir il s'appelle mollier tas
comme élire molière même 400 ans après
sa naissance c'était en janvier 1622 à
paris le comédien continue d'être
célébrée partout tout le temps
et
la fontaine molière la fontaine molière
la rue molière le lycée molière ou
encore la maison de molière plus connu
sous le nom de comédie française depuis
son inauguration en 1680 on n'y a joué
le tartuffe
jeu date votre habit les toffes on est
moelleuse l'avare
[Musique]
ou encore le malade imaginaire des
milliers de fois et avant de monter sur
scène les artistes ont leur petit rituel
fait une petite caresse et tous les
comédiens en passant ne peuvent pas
s'empêcher de faire une symboliquement
c'est une sorte de
molière a aussi donné son nom à une
cérémonie la nuit des molières célèbre
le monde du théâtre depuis 1987 pour la
première édition en guise d'intro
l'acteur jean le poulain rendait un
vibrant hommage au dramaturge
je crois que ce dont nous remercions
surtout molière ici ce soir
et chaque fois que nous pensons à lui
dans le secret de notre coeur c'est
d'avoir été un homme il faut croire que
c'est une qualité assez rare jeune homme
de lettres pour avoir suscité trop
d'amour d'étonnement et de fidélité et
c'est pas fini plusieurs villes rendent
aussi hommage à molière versailles par
exemple où a lieu chaque année depuis
1996 un festival de musique et de
théâtre le mois molière ce portrait
d'un fort vie d'un soupçon je me sens
l'âme
mais aussi à pézenas dans l'hérault
molière y est une figure il y à ces
journées jouées avec sa troupe de
l'illustré théâtre pendant des années
alors tous les ans depuis 2001 l'auteur
du bourgeois gentilhomme est aussi mis à
l'honneur lors d'un festival
mourir ma fille me font bon dieu
2022 c'est l'année molière un peu
partout en france des événements
culturels vont célébrer les 400 ans de
la naissance du dramaturge
au programme des pièces de théâtre des
festivals mais aussi des balles et des
expositions et en mai à versailles le
statut de molière sera aussi inauguré
[Musique]